[موسيقى]
عندما نشأت في علامات العاصمة وكانت
حراقات الكتابة على الجدران هي صوت
الأشخاص غير المعترف بهم في كثير من الأحيان في
مدينة معزولة ،
لكن الآن متحف الجرافيتي في الشارع الرابع عشر
يمنح الناس فرصة
لرعاية ثقافة فن الشارع ،
لا أفعل  تعرف أي شيء عن
مشهد فن الشارع في العاصمة ، من
الواضح أننا رأينا أن نشأتك كانت
جزءًا من الهروب من المكان الذي نعيش فيه ، لكنني
لم أكن أعرف أي شيء عن
الثقافة ، فالأمر يتعلق كثيرًا
بكونك شخصًا أصغر سنًا وأنك
للتعبير عن نفسك ، عليك أن تقوم
ceta sedelli المعروفة أيضًا باسم miss che love
ترسم جدران العاصمة بأعمال فنية
تعكس ماضيها
مع التركيز على النساء الأقوياء من اللون والثقافات
الأصلية في الثمانينيات كانت مدينة الشوكولاتة هذه
الحركة السرية الكاملة للكتابة على
الجدران  صخرة حركة الهيب هوب بأكملها
كانت أيضًا لكنها كانت تتفجر ، لذا أعني بالنسبة
لي وأقول إننا كنا مثل الأطفال الذين
نشأوا في هذا العصر
لأن واحدًا من تسعة هو مبدع ثقافي
لديه شغف بإخبار  القصص
سواء كان ذلك من خلال وضع العلامات أو التصوير ،
ما أعتقد أنه رائع حول مساري
كفنان هو آه حقًا قد ظهر للتو من
خلال فن الكتابة على الجدران من خلال هذا ،
فأنت تعلم أخلاقيات DIY فقط بفهم
أن كل ما تريد أن تجعله
عليك أن تجعل نفسك
مثل العاصمة  كما أعني من جميع الجوانب ، هو
مزيج من العديد من الطبقات المختلفة التي
تعرفها من وسط المدينة ، الحكومة ،
مؤسسة سميثسونيان إلى أناكوستيا ،
بوتوماك ، إنه مزيج من الكثير من
الكتابة على الجدران بالنسبة لي كانت تلك القناة
لتنفجر نفسي حقًا على نطاق واسع
أنت تعرفك  يجب أن تفكر في التوقيت
الذي يجب أن تعمل فيه بسرعة كبيرة ،
عليك أن تفكر في المكان الذي تتواجد فيه ،
عليك التفكير في الوقت الذي تكون فيه
هناك
حتى مجرد فهم موازنة اللون بأشكال الحروف على نطاق واسع
ما يمكن قراءته
من مسافة ما يمكن قراءته من
قطار يتحرك ما يمكن قراءته
على الحائط حيث يمر القطار ،
وأنت حرفياً تسير
هكذا وترى كما في الأقسام كيف يمكنك
اللعب بذلك
إنه أمر لا يصدق أن رسومات DC على الجدران
أصبحت شكلاً فنيًا محترمًا في
المجتمع يقف من أجل الحرية والإبداع لإعادة
تشكيل هوية
المنطقة ، لذا جربها
[موسيقى]
هناك ،
لقد حصلت عليها ، نعم ، هل لديك علامة
تكبر عندما  هل أنت في الجنوب الشرقي ،
هل لم أذكر مطلقًا ، هل
لديك اسم مستعار كنت معروفًا جدًا
باسم الصبي الأبيض ولم
يكن أبدًا إهانة ، لقد كان في الواقع
مصطلحًا محببًا ، كنت أخف
رجل في
جواري واسمي ليس كذلك  كارلتون الرائع جدًا
ليس اسمًا جيدًا جدًا ، ومن ثم لماذا احتجت إلى
لقب ، فإن الاسم كارلتون لا
يعطي الكثير من المصداقية في الشارع ، فلا أحد
يخيفه رجل يدعى كارلتون
بغض النظر عن مدى كوني ،
أنت أفضل بكثير في هذا مني  أنا
كنت